es war nur ein bisschen party auf dem
ballhausplatz am samstagabend im
kanzleramt hatte sebastian kurz gerade
seinen rücktritt verkündet für die linke
anlass zum feiern aber so richtig
stimmung wollte nicht aufkommen denn es
war ja nur ein bisschen rücktritt so
sieht es auch johannes sourcing
[Musik]
bundeskanzlerin kommen auch ein kurzes
nicht ganz weg ist es ist auf jeden fall
kein tag für große feier die kommt
hoffentlich bald aber heute ist nicht
der richtige tag der hausdurchsuchung im
kanzleramt ermittlungen wegen korruption
und untreue peinliche chatprotokolle
sebastian kurz war als kanzler nicht
mehr haltbar doch er tritt nur zur seite
so lässt man wissen ein schatten kanzler
auf einflussreichen posten ich selbst
werde als parteiobmann und als
klubobmann ins parlament zurückkehren
und dort versuchen meinen beitrag zu
leisten
wie lange wird er sich da halten können
es ist jedenfalls der tiefpunkt einer
karriere die ebenso brillant wie
beschämend verlief
umjubelt war der polit jung-star der
versprach die alte verstaubte vp zu
erneuern
türkis jung und slim fit doch die welle
der begeisterung war damals in teilen
wohl frisiert umfragewerte und artikel
in der zeitung österreich waren bestellt
und mit steuergeld bezahlt so der
vorwurf der staatsanwaltschaft
deshalb wohl beim aufstieg kurz wurde
jüngster bundeskanzler österreichs und
zog die ganze partei
alles mit dem versprechen es anders zu
machen
der heutige tag ist ein historischer der
heutige tag ist unsere chance die
führung in diesem land zu übernehmen und
für echte veränderung in österreich zu
sagen vielen dank
vorarlberg ganz im westen österreichs
auch hier gibt es eine vp geführte
landesregierung auch hier glaubten sie
dem versprechen des neuen stils bis
jetzt
an alle denkt super cool water ein junge
und jetzt also ich für den absolut nicht
drin was soll das ausland davon denken
wenn jemand uns so repräsentiert
erschreckend
ist dass leighton
hier regen vor allem kurz politische
machenschaften auf die chatprotokolle
zeigen dass kurt seinem
innerparteilichen konkurrenten keinen
erfolg könnte
1,2 milliarden für nachmittagsbetreuung
von kindern seien gar nicht gut so
schreibt er einen vertrauten im
finanzministerium wie kannst du das
aufhalten
in der svp sitzt rainer keckeis nicht
ganz vorn aber als chef der
arbeiterkammer hat er das ohr und der
basis aber angetan von kurz sagt er bis
er so was lars giesen was wird da ein
partei grande genannt kurz wortwahl ist
ähnlich jetzt wissen wir dahinter steckt
ein ganz anderer mensch dahinter steckt
ein machtgeile arroganter mensch dem
andere leute völlig egal sind und der
sich einer wortwahl auch bedient die
eigentlichen der politik so nicht
stattfinden durfte das hat was mit
anstand zu tun mit werten zu tun und
davon hat daher kurz offenbar viel
weniger also wir ja nach außen
vorgegeben hat dabei gab sich kurz
besonders in seiner ersten amtszeit als
bollwerk des anstands das ebita video
löste damals einen politischen skandal
aus der spätere vize kanzler strache
zeigte sich bestechlich und wollte die
presse gegangen
zack zack zack journalisten weg positive
berichterstattung her fertig ist der
wahlsieg zur strache kanzler kurz zeigt
sich empört aber wirklich schwerwiegend
und problematisch ist das sind die ideen
des machtmissbrauchs die ideen zum
umgang mit österreichischen
steuergeldern natürlich auch das
verständnis gegenüber der
medienlandschaft in unserem land
das cover der zeitschrift news
thematisiert die hybris der macht der
geschäftsführer hat sie selbst erlebt
guter journalismus ist teuer in
österreich hilft der staat den medien in
dem er viel inseriert ein einfallstor
für einflussnahme das övp geführte
finanzministerium stoppte hier im juli
alle inserate
der grund lag darin dass es eine
kritische berichterstattung
über türkis in der regierung dass wir
uns damit kritisch auseinandergesetzt
haben bei ihm läuft es wohl anders herum
wolfgang fellners zeitung ist erreicht
bekommt viele inserate sie druckten die
kurz freundlichen umfragen und artikel
koordiniert vom kurz netzwerk zeigen die
chats fellner ist ein kapitalist simst
ein kurz vertrauter dar wer zahlt
schafft an ich liebe das die zeitung
österreich ist kein sonderfall meint man
bei news
es ist hier die
spitze des eisbergs adressiert wurden
das sagt noch wenig darüber aus was da
sonst noch über und unter wasser
stattgefunden habe dass da auch
politisch noch nicht alles rausgekommen
ist das gefühl hat auch die wg von
johannes eissing
ein neuer bundeskanzler eine verhaftung
noch ein u-ausschuss jeden tag was neues
das ist die house of cards nur traurige
beschäftigt sich nur mit sich selbst und
wir kommen trotzdem raus wir haben das
seit die mitte mit u ausschüssen etc
nachdem wir das sogar die erste aus
dieser 100 verachtet und
selig sind wochen einige sehr gespannt
es gibt jedenfalls genug futter für
lange wege abend nicht nur hier erwarten
sie nun auf das vielleicht letzte
kapitel der saga kurz
[Musik]